my household incomes about 200 000 a
year okay but 85 of it is my primary job
and I'm not happy with it okay I want to
do life coaching and help others but I
grew up poor so my mentalities I can't
go backwards in life and take an income
pay cut like that 115 000 a year is a
lot of money it is I feel like I'm going
down but that's a theory yeah you're
unhappy yeah yeah you've taken the
concept of taking a step backwards for
two steps forward as worse than being
unhappy every day that's crazy an
ideology is [__] up your day to day
but how do I retrain my brain by
realizing you're being ridiculous
like by this moment yeah like you'll be
back if you get all those hours back
you're going to get back to 202 years
yeah that's true so what do you want to
be bougie for one more year
another pair of sneakers yeah
sure so go
steps you're literally of course you're
on a happy day to day what the [__] is
that worth sounds like a lot more than
85 000 a [__] year